[Music]
okay discus usa
we have decided to play very
positionally with black
and there's nothing quite as solid and
positional as the queen's gambit
as you guys know i play the king's
indian but at the
first part of the speedrun we're going
to play a very solid opening so d45 he
goes g3
fiancee the bishop it's not a
particularly
uh dangerous line it's not it's not a
terrible line um
and there's nothing that we should do in
particular other than just to develop
our pieces so
we're going to develop our pieces and
as you know in the queen's gambit
declined you go c4 east well bishop h3
okay
so yesterday i discussed a little bit
about the sort of the philosophy of
fiance in the bishop
and the drawbacks of fiance he's really
illustrating the drawbacks for us he
goes bishop h3 offering a trade of
bishops
should we accept this trade
yeah it's yeah definitely because
because now he's got these holes
immediately on on the light squares
and this is a very favorable trade for
us
if i were playing normally i would
consider quickly running the h-bond down
but let's
let's stick to the fundamentals here and
remember that white is not
doing anything in the center and already
he's got a very awkward night let's
first of all let's make a note to
ourselves that this knight is undefended
so we should be looking for various
forks and various moves like queen c
it's not that effective right now but if
we wanted to make a greater claim in the
center
there's no reason that we can't play c5
ourselves right it's like we're almost
playing a queen's gamut ourselves with
black
and it's the same mechanism we're trying
to displace the pawn and if the pawn
takes r pawn
well i'll show this after the game i
guess he will take the pawn
um and as in the queen's gambit accepted
for white
we have the exact same ways of
trying to recapture this pawn and
gaining control of the center
okay so bishop e3 by our opponent
is an awkward move it's again he isn't
doing anything
horrible yet but things are definitely
not looking great for him
so i guess he's trying to he's trying to
support his central pawn
what should we do here we can definitely
take on d4
but then he centralizes his bishop i
don't really want to help him in that
way
so again when in doubt there's nothing
specific that should be done let's just
develop our knight to c6
and again we're trying to provoke him
into taking on on c5 okay he goes c3
he's actually not playing that badly
here okay
so now we can continue our development
in several different ways because he's
developed
quite awkwardly we can consider
opening up the center just a little bit
with the move e5
but again i'm going to continue playing
super super solid chess i'm actually
going to play e6 we're going to keep the
center relatively close
deliberately because i want to show you
guys how to play those resulting
positions he goes dc5 now he takes
okay um
now i guess that was the idea of bishop
e3
was to tie himself to that pawn
now um let me think about this for a
second
so there's a couple of approaches that
we could take here once again
and a lot of you guys are proposing an
excellent move here which is to play
knight g4
hitting the bishop threatening to ruin
white's pawn structure but the secondary
point of this move
is that if the bishop moves away we take
on c5 or regain the pawn and we're in
phenomenal shape um
so these positions may be unfamiliar to
some of you
with with pawns on c5 like that why can
play the move b two to b4 you'll see
this often
uh in many different types of positions
he goes bishop g5 that's a good move
how should we respond to this how should
we respond to this
yeah so never play f6 right except when
you play f6
and the point of f6 is to attack the
bishop we need to make a move with tempo
so that when his bishop moves we can
immediately take on c5
now okay so we can also
delay bishop takes c5 and make what
additional move
exploiting the bishop being on f4 oh
jimmy
feingold is in the chat that's hilarious
ben
is in the chat that's actually so funny
what's up ben
exactly so e5 would be a very tempting
move
but again i'm going to hold myself back
what is the drawback of a move like e5
which by the way is an excellent move
but nonetheless if you had to name a
drawback of that move
what is it
it's that it weakens like it weakens the
light squares it weakens f5 and e6 it
also weakens
the d5 pawn and in the name of playing
solidly we're going to take on c5 we're
going to keep
the center solid we're going to keep the
light squares protected
um he's probably going to castle this
guy is not playing badly um
at all so of course there's probably at
several points we could have played
slightly more
accurately but so far we're just playing
solitude because before it's actually
bishop let's keep the bishop on this
diagonal but should be six
okay b5
where should we go
yeah so we should keep the knight closer
to the center 97 is fine
i like 95 i like situations where the
knights are linked
and uh you know there's nothing you know
amazing about this move or nothing
amazingly deep
the knight could go to c4 from here
thank you
and best six but the bottom line is he's
not developing
his pieces and by pushing his pawn to b5
he's making a lot more weaknesses on his
queen side now but this pawn is backward
and isolated well not isolated it's
backward pawn
bottom b5 isn't too good either so
okay knight e3 so he's he's making like
a good effort to develop his pieces and
stuff
but he's not doing it in a very coherent
way and his position is going to start
to crumble
now castling here is very logical and
we're going to do it
um and we should now kind of think about
what our subsequent plan is going to be
what do we even attack here
so nights are very bad the knights are
on the rim there's
many good plans in this position so i'll
highlight two
separate ideas the first is on the queen
side the second is on the kingston so
what is the biggest target let's think
in terms of targets
the biggest target on the queen side is
the pawn on c3
what is a very typical and very solid
way to attack that pawn
so we go rook c8 occupying the semi-open
file and he can go rook c1
but then his rook is tied down to the
protection of the pawn i've talked about
it
this at length previously the fact that
it's not only about
winning upon often you can use the
weakness of the pawn or the weakness of
anything
square to tie down your opponent's
pieces which would force them
uh to do nothing but defend that pawn
and then you could reallocate your
resources and your opponent often can
reallocate his
okay all right
that's right
okay
so he's deciding whether to defend this
now i mentioned a
king side target he does it with a queen
what is the king side
target how do we exploit it
so the target is the h3 knight i've
mentioned this previously
we can say well how can i go about
attacking that knight and preparing the
attack
uh there's many again there's so many
good moves here i almost struggle to
decide myself but a very typical
maneuver is getting this queen at h5
right
uh often this is seen in certain
sicilian lines with white
but this is a maneuver that's as old as
the hills it assembles the pieces on the
king side
it will attack the knight and it will
create the potential for an attack by
the way when i'm playing solidly with
black
that's not to say i'm not going to ever
attack the king i'm going to do what the
position demands
but you guys can see that i'm making
like a making certain choices that are
that are more solid that are more uh
development-based
um and hopefully that's that's turning
out decently
okay so rook c1 we're going to complete
the maneuver queen
h5 and he has really only one move he's
gotta find king g2 bringing the king up
supporting the knife that is just you
know his position is really on its last
legs
i hope he finds it because it's gonna
give us a chance to think constructively
in that subsequent position
so let me walk you through
he finds it what i'm seeing in this
position now what i'm seeing
is this bishop on f4 you guys are also
saying it what am i seeing about it well
this bishop's pathway back is blocked by
the queen
it's only out is the knight on e5 right
we're on the same page about this so and
but but when i start looking at this
knight i'm like wait a second
maybe i could try to go knight c4 right
attack the queen and then i could go e5
or g5
uh but there's an issue with that too
which is that this a39
it may seem bad but it's actually
contesting that c4 square
so working back one more step what move
can we come up with to enable knight c4
yeah bishop c5 bishop c5 attacks tonight
i hope you guys follow the logic there
the knight is going to move then we go
knight c4 attacking the queen and then
this bishop no longer has that exit path
by taking the knight
we can attack the bishop and either trap
it right off the bat
or make a further dent in white's
defensive
resources so notice
how flexible we are at first we we're
attacking the c pawn
but we stop on a dime we switch gears we
again do what the position demands of us
nobody um you know says that your play
has to be
totally consistent from the first move
to the last and he plays a very nice
move queen b2 actually he
this guy is is is he's not bad he's not
easy to beat
now this is actually not this doesn't
actually stop
our our threat right what can we do
we can play and i'm going to speed up
just a little bit we can take the remove
the defender right
it's painful to to part ways with our
bishop which was a really nice bishop
but
i believe that the effect of knight c4
is going to be
so vast that it's going to uh make it
okay to give up that bishop because e5
is going to be devastating
unless he finds some crazy defensive
resource which i'm not seeing
okay he takes on a7 be my guest e5
oh he wants bishop b3 yeah no he's
playing well he's playing well but it's
not gonna help
i think
so after bishop e3 what can we do
robbie thank you so much
yeah we go d4 so the problem is after
bishop b3 if we try to take on e3 and
then take again we're like yeah
the queen on a7 is defending that bishop
or that pawn
so there's a couple of tactics that come
to our aid in that kind of situation the
first is like an interception tactic
or i think it's called interference um
and interference is when
you know there's a connection between
two pieces and you break that connection
preferably with tempo
okay i don't know about that move
i don't know about that move but
yes carson wentz instantly found this
tactic i'll treat myself to a candy
after this one
all right he makes it a little bit
easier for us but the bishop is still
trapped the fact remains
okay obviously now we're up
a gazillion pieces
but if you want to finish this one
clinically
one unstoppable winning plan would be to
pile up on this night even further what
i know this sounds ridiculous like
coming up with a plan we're up 400
pieces
what um plan can you suggest to pile up
on the knight
so knight e3 yeah okay let's just kind
of you know what i was thinking about a
rook lift i was thinking about going
f5 and then rook f6 or h6 but that's
that's not necessary right now let's go
knight e3 and just
take his rook take his knight it's over
boom
yeah so now order of operations we can
take the knight
we can take the rook it doesn't matter
i'm going to take the knight because the
knight is a stronger attacker than the
rook is the defender we don't need more
material
right now we need to go for trek mate
right and this is one thing that you
will see
at at this level and we'll we'll see
this a lot more at like a 13 1400 level
when i reach
that rating okay he's really giving us a
full
buffet let's take this guy uh which is
that
you'll often see players you know
competing at a very high level for a
long time but then at some point just
collapsing completely and when there's
one small mistake it often is followed
by just like complete total collapse
okay so queen c1 i guess i'm not
commentating this part of the game and
he resigns and we're over 800
well done okay good that was a well well
played game
for sure all right
so d4d5
now c4 is the queen's gambit declined
right so the queen's gamut declined
uh and or no no sorry this is the
queen's gamut we were going to play the
queen's game and declined
by no means do you have to play the
queen's gambit declined
um dc the queen's gamut accepted is
perfectly legitimate
opening as well and there's a couple of
well there's the slav which is another
form of declining the queen's gambit and
you know as some of you may know there's
the baltic bishop f5 this is a sideline
but it can be a very dangerous one i've
shown this to hafu
knight c6 is the chagoran so there's a
lot of options for black against the
queen's gambit um
but our opponent played g3 so after
knight f6
bishop g2 is of course the logical
continuation and here
some players will play as they would in
a queen's gamba decline so they play e6
but e6 is not the best move black can
get more out of this position
what would you propose here with black
yeah so bishop f5 is the clinical mode
bishop f5
defend develops the bishop outside the
pawn chain
right and this concept i'll often use
this and you might what do you mean by
that well all this means is that
after when you play e6 right the bishop
is locked in if you play bishop f5 first
and then play e6 the bishop has made it
out
now you can defend the d5 onto your
heart's content this is also the
philosophy of an opening like the london
right so you're basically playing the
london system um
against the catalan or against some sort
of weird
fianchetto opening and white is super
solid here people play like this but
that would be one good way to respond
not that e6 is bad but
he was bishop h3 we take it and now we
strike in the center with c5
um so what would we have done if he had
taken immediately
now again recall the term
gambit mentality and gamma mentality
applies equally to
queen's gambit openings and king's
gambit openings the gamma mentality says
that when you sacrifice a pawn or more
for
activity you you should you should a
be ready to sacrifice even more if
that's what's required and b you
shouldn't rush to
cover the pawn at all costs like queen
a5 recovers the pawn at all costs but
remember you're not developing your
pieces you're moving your queen around a
bunch
and you're giving your opponent a chance
to develop the tempo that would defeat
the purpose
of the gambit in the first place so a
good move here would be e5
um but a more measured idea would also
be to play
um just nice e6 yeah knight c6 you don't
need to rush to
get rid of this pawn if white wants to
bend over backwards
and save this spawn let let him do that
then you're going to have a huge
development advantage you're going to
have a beautiful center
you're going to have massive
compensation for the pawn
um
yeah how did how did it help us well
just visually you should see that
the pawn is displaced right the d4 pawn
was controlling
a central square it was in the center
now it's offset
to the side of the center and
particularly if we play e5 you'll see
this in stark
relief the fact that now we have full
control over the key central squares
um but i do want to mention
let's assume that after knight c6 white
would have castled the movie 5 is
actually not necessarily the best one
because as i said
this central arrangement um creates a
liability on d5 this pawn is not
defended by any other pawn so what can
white do here
to soften up black's control of the d5
pawn and again
this is good for black 2 but i just want
to illustrate a point here
so c4 is is possible but not scary i can
either take on c4 i can move past it
but the move bishop g5 is actually quite
nasty in these positions because
um because after bishop c5 bishop f6
you run into an issue or if you take on
f6 with the queen and you drop the d5
pawn if you take with the pawn
well you know this is fine but now you
have to reckon with
your pawn structure on the king side
being ruined black is
doing it amazingly here he can castle
queen side but i'm
illustrating a general point rather than
this position specifically
no i don't know about that man i'm
flattered
uh you're the og okay so
[Music]
after let's see so c5 i hope that makes
sense
curious gifting to ben ben thank you
go ben so bishop e3
knight c6 your lessons are just
they're not just fine they're gold um
so after an ic6 again it's the same
thing after dc
we could go e6 we could go e5 so c3
e6 i'm just developing normally d takes
c5 he finally takes the pawn and here we
go knight g4
so i hope this move makes sense we're
just hitting the bishop
a lot of you guys were asking what
happens if he goes bishop d4
and the idea bishop d4 is that if knight
takes d4 he plays cd and he builds
pawn chain we don't want this so what
should black do here
e5 is correct now we go e5 way tech the
bishop bishop has no squares
has to go back to e3 we take it oh look
at this
and now bishop c5 with an amazing
position
um i hope that makes sense so for that
reason bishop g5 was sensible we go f6
it goes bishop f4 once again
the temptation here was to play e5 but
it would have softened up the d5 planet
i wasn't sure i wanted this
i think we have enough control of the
center here so
the bottom line here the lesson is
controlling the center is
you know it's not something where you do
it's a matter of diminishing returns
like at first the first
two squares that you control is huge
it's important
after everything after that has to be
weighed against the negatives thank you
embase gifting to
red gryffindor would bishop b7 be okay
yeah it would be fine
but the issue here is that you do allow
white the opportunity to cling to the
plot
before and um
you know i did just say that black is
still good here you know black is
like as good control of the center but i
didn't want to give him that extra
opportunity
so f6 bishop c5
and you know i think white should have
he had the right idea at this point
white is already in pretty big trouble
but knight d2 would have been a more
central developing square
would have been better knight a3 the
knight really is out of commission here
castles castles rook c8 so we attacked
the pawn rook
queen d2 again should have played roxy
one probably
abiding by the rule that you should you
know you shouldn't use a piece of higher
value to do something that you can
do with a piece of lower value now we go
queen e8
getting the queen around to h5 rook ac
one
queen h5 and he finds king g2 but now
this key move bishop c5
trying to open up the c4 square for the
knight so that we can then set in motion
the e or the g pawn
and uh cause tremendous difficulty to
this bishop
i buy it all the time so i wanted to
show one really really cool tactic
if he had moved his knight back and we
had gone knight c4
and then he brought his queen up to d3 i
have two questions for you guys
first of all if you did decide to attack
this bishop between e5 and g5
which should be preferred
so we're split the answer is g5
yeah e5 drops the d5 pawn with check
unfortunately
that's why i always say when you make a
move like this in the center you have to
understand what's been left behind what
is no longer protected
as robert says what changes as a result
of the last move particularly with very
committal moves that should be checked
uh no pun intended and we dropped the
knight trapped upon the check it's not
good
but black has also in addition to a g5 a
very pretty tactical
idea i'll tell you the first um
of those of the moves bishop takes f2
looks pretty wild right well first of
all you might say well this blunders the
bishop
but that opens up the queen's path to h2
and then we drop the knight back
with the fork but white can try to be
smarter than that and play rook takes f2
right you can try to get two pieces for
the rook and in this position
black has a very pretty tactical concept
does anybody
see it and i will show you guys this
time the
uh one of the the most famous
applications of this exact pattern
very famous and finale to a game
which i will find as you guys ponder
let's move
yeah queen h3s right
yeah all right and i found the game
i just gotta set up let me let me first
show the concept itself
so uh queen h3 drawing the king into h3
then taking the rook with a fork
and if you count the material at the end
of it black has an extra exchange
now how did i know to look for this
well let's take a quick peek at a famous
finale okay this is not ideal alignment
but
it'll do a trojan against spassky in
their world championship match 1966.
so this whole game was very very famous
we won't and spassky is literally behind
me
it's that pretty meta behind me i'm
resigning to spassky here spassky will
be resigning to the trojan
um 38 years before i resigned to spassky
and it is white to play and win
so who sees the combination
okay a lot of you guys are seeing the
right idea but you've got to be very
careful about the execution queen 8
shade
is the right idea but after king takes a
treat you need whole board awareness
right here you're like yeah i'm winning
the queen back i'll have two pieces for
a rook in a winning
end game no rook takes f7 the rookie
merges out of nowhere
and takes the knight so first you have
to take the
the rook with the bishop uh spassky
recaptured
now you play queen h8 drawing the king
into h8 lowering the king and now knight
takes f7
he resigned after queen eh fork and at
the end were simply a piece up in the
endgame
so spassky resigned after queen h.a
who's
who said that petrossian uh never had
cool combinations that's absolutely
untrue yeah that knight on a5 is
not a good one that's for sure this was
a king's indian by the way
okay um so that is
sort of a similar pattern you can i
think and this is a pretty common
tactical idea it's not the only game
where this happened
but hopefully it helps you remember this
concept um
and queen b2 was our opponent's move we
take the knight we go knight c4
and here we we go e5 because the d5 pawn
is no longer
hanging okay had he
he went queen c5 but had he gone bishop
e3 we would have gotten d4
right i think magnus might be up there
and this is an interference tactic
because if he takes then we take on e3
and we win
the rook we win the knight and black
white's position collapses that's not
the only move
um you could also try a move like rook
to a8 but the queen could try to be
stubborn here and cling to this bishop
and also now it's attacking d5 with
chuck so
um this is i think a little bit
imprecise and i'm actually not sure what
black can do here to win the game
quickly i mean black can just go rook
fd8 or something
and of course we're still dominating but
uh but but that would be
the difficulty of that okay so
that's uh that's the bottom line well he
went queen c5 we take it and the game is
over
i think it's time i hit the sack guys
it's been
well it's already been a five hour
stream almost um let's play one encore
game
one more one last one
and uh then we'll we'll wrap up for
today
okay so let's get
that last game on the road our bad deca
okay
e3 we've already faced one
reverse french we've already faced one
reverse french
um okay this time he goes queen to e2
that is that is not a good move because
it blocks the bishop
from from developing right blocks the
bishop from developing
and uh our response to these kinds of
moves
is one and the same we go down the
checklist do we can we control the
center
uh can we can we get our pieces out and
here we can do both we can control the
center with d5
then we can start getting our pieces out
and this would yes now he goes e4
so the question here is should we should
we take on e4
should we take on e4 should we go d4 or
should we
ignore so what we shouldn't do is go d4
so as i explained yesterday d4 closes up
the center
and when you close up the center you
lessen
the effect of a development advantage
becomes harder to exploit a development
advantage because the center is closed
it's more clogged up
and it's hard to get anything done so in
reality you should try to open up the
center as quickly as possible because
he's done nothing but move his queen
and a development advantage while we
don't have one yet
we are about to have one because his
queen is going to be stuck in the
in the middle so let's take the pun
right
let's take the pawn now we go knight c6
we develop the knight and defend
e5 then we might go knight f6
with tempo we by the way could have gone
knight f6 immediately and actually
sacrificed this one
in order to open up the e file but we're
trying to play more solidly so
no need for that we might sacrifice upon
at some point if he goes bishop b5 for
example
so does the logic here make sense right
we we welcome
an opening of the center knight f6 would
have been good too knight f6 would have
been good too
uh but i just want to illustrate the
general logic here d take c4 is
is i think more pure from that point of
view okay
so again f5 would not only would it lose
the e pawn the issue with the move like
f5 is it doesn't get a piece out
it actually weakens the king and again i
think you're making this move because
i'm attacking the queen it's with tempo
but the move itself has to accomplish
something it's not enough for a move to
attack
your opponent's queen uh the move has to
accomplish something apart from that
okay knight f3 now we go net f6
right e5 is defended and he can't take
it with a knight because we take his
queen
we got royalty in the chat
maybe i should have gone f6 just to take
some some grandmasters off
all right
queen c4 so he's
throwing more oil onto the fire he's
allowing us to continue developing with
tempo
how can we do that bishop b6 is right
yup
he should have probably just gotten his
going back to asap now
the development advantage becomes scary
now the development advantage becomes
scary
this is the last game
why is he not developing his speed well
he's he's moving his queen around i mean
his queen is attacked so
you know it's okay so queen e2 which is
correct
now there's two approaches here i can
guarantee you that some i'm sure that
some of you are thinking about e4
attacking the knight but let's
be very let's be almost obsessive in
this case about completing our in this
case i think we should be obsessed about
completing
completing our development and we should
also tempt him into taking the pawn on
e5
so alex i'll talk about moves like
knight before afterward
so let's get this bishop out where
should we put it forget for a second
about defending the spawn
if that wasn't on our priority list
where would you put the bishop yeah
bishop steven yeah exactly
you just illustrated it so bishop c5 why
are we not concerned about taking home
because our development advantage has
reached
biblical proportions um
and upon taking the pawn 95 would
actually help us
open up the e file and it would hasten
his demise
okay so he goes b3 tries to if he can
get out of the bishop
he's not going to have time for it now
we could castle
but at this point we've gotten all of
our miners out
we could also play that movie e4 which
would be
much stronger now that we've developed
all of our miners let's do it let's go
e4
right so why are we not castling why are
we not worried about it well he's
he doesn't have any of the resources
necessary to
punish us for not castling he doesn't
have any pieces out at all
i still would have preferred castling
but you know this is a fun move and
it's the last game of the day so let's
have some fun
okay you know i know there's a lot of
you have specific questions like why
didn't we go here or there
that always happens when we've got these
games and again
please note that there are many good
moves in a position like this
really and you shouldn't get too
uh upset about like why didn't we do
this like you know i don't get why this
was
it probably means your move was good too
now
what should we do now we can just go
after him
at this point he's so underdeveloped
that we can just go after him we can go
knight d4
and you know am i being hypocritical
here am i making a move just because it
attacks the queen no
well i'm centralizing the knight i'm
also hitting c2 i'm forcing the queen
back literally
okay well i'm not forcing the queen back
but it would have been a good idea to
put
put it back now we take it and i'll talk
about what we would have done there
after the game and this game is over
all right and he's probably not feeling
too hot right now
yeah i mean again these people don't
know this you know
okay knight c3 so
we can take on c3 we can also return to
d4
to attack the pawn
and uh goes d3 now we take with a fork
i'm going to go
a little bit faster through this final
stage of the game i think you guys get
the point
i take say one
and um the game is over
well i mean the game's done quickly but
i think when you are a beginner the
opening is the most important stage of
the game so it's not a bad thing the
game is done quickly
uh you know and when we okay so bishop
is good you know he's winning the night
there's many approaches here uh in such
situations by the way when you do get
your night trapped
the classic approach is how can we give
this knight up for as much as possible
right if we're already losing our knight
how can we take out as much material as
possible
it's not as necessary to do this here
because we're already up a queen in a
rook but
i'll still do it right n knight takes b3
we can give the knight up for two pawns
we can shatter his queen sign we can
pull the king out so this would be
um this would be what you would do if
like
you know if you weren't a gazillion
pieces okay now he lets us pull our
knight out
to d4 and uh
yeah he's he's probably going to resign
bishop f5 is coming in
just gonna let's just take the pawn
let's just open up the position
castle now we are gonna castle right it
bothers me that our king is still in the
center something about that is
pushing my buttons
castles
yeah now we should notice that we're
skewering
his king let's take the knight whatever
i'm i'm playing very fast here guys
there's not
there isn't very much to explain here
this is the battery
and we are attacking f2
and then after knight d1 we go queen g4
check okay let's take this guy
and now the king and the bishop are on
the same file so we're going to bring
the rook into the game
and win the bishop so a battery is when
you stack one piece
on another piece but both
like in the direction of that first
piece like if you stack
a rook and a bishop up on top of each
other that's not a battery right
um if you put a queen in a bishop in a
diagonal that's better if you put a
queen in a rook in a file
that's a battery rook takes c3 check
um
queen e1 is coming in queen d1 and then
knight e4
queen takes c1 is right i think takes c3
queen d1 check and then 94 is checkmate
94's check me
yeah okay
good game so
the bottom line here is that
after e3 5 queen e2 d5 e4
do you take c4 um
yeah this is already bad like this is
bad enough this
opens up the center and now we're just
developing our pieces developing our
pieces
uh bishop e6 the only thing i really
want to mention is what would have
happened if knight takes c5 well we
would have taken the knight
there's two approaches here there is a
tactical
move that wins the pawn back with great
effect that's the best move what is
black's best movie or what am i talking
about
if you've done your puzzles you'll see
this quickly
that's bishop f6 all right good night
bishop oh sorry bishop takes f2
and if he takes then that's a fork
against the queen if the king moves well
then the king has lost castling rights
but
even if we drop the bishop back and then
castle chances are
he's going to get in big trouble because
of the development advantage so he won
b3 we go e4
if he had dropped his queen back we
would have sizzled his queen with bishop
g4
this is absolutely look at this position
crushing
and we could even play bishop f3 you
know give him a like this but
we can also just castle and do a bunch
of different things here so
um i'll definitely talk more at length
about
converting these kinds of advantages
when you're like crushing how do you
actually find
the crushing move but you cannot castle
while in check and you cannot castle
through a check
but after queen v5 everything was very
very straightforward
so anyways guys um what if
they try to block your bishop with f3 so
if f3
then we take on f3 and again as in many
of these positions we can move the
knight away anywhere even to e4
and threaten queen h4 checkmate and
again four pieces against zero
this is absolutely this is absolute
demolition
okay um so let's call it a night
i'm gonna i'm gonna get some shut eye
it's uh again very very early start
tomorrow
um and uh
hope you guys enjoyed we're we're 8 45
right now and on the speed run
uh and i think when we get to like a
thousand eleven hundred the games will
start to get longer
but for the time being we're working on
mastering those opening principles
um thank you everybody so much for the
support uh we're
on the doorstep of six thousand subs i
really
appreciate that
[Music]